اقر الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم بمقتل
ضابط وجندي من وحده النخبه يه هلوم
المختصه بمكافحه الانفاق في معارك بشمال
غزه وجنوبها ما يرفع عدد قتلاه الى تسعه
في يوم واحد واعلنت وسال اعلام اسرائيليه
ان اربعه من بين الضباط والجنود التسعه هم
من قوات النخبه في الجيش كما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان 29 جنديا اصيبوا في معارك
غزه خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه وكشفت مراسله
الشؤون العسكريه في الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
الرسميه ان القتلى ينتمون لوحدات كوماندوس
النخبه دف دفان ولوم وقد قتلوا في معارك
مع كتائب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
جنوب وشمال قطاع غزه ونقلت الاذاعه عن
مصادر عسكريه ان قوات الجيش تواجه مقاومه
قويه وتخوض قتالا ضاريا وقاسيا في جميع
المحاور التي تعمل فيها تحديدا في مدينه
خانيونس جنوبي القطاع وحي الشجاعيه ومخيم
جباليه في
الشمال